The the first thing I want to address
right away is her same God assertions
like um Christians and Muslims believe
all the same God. That that's like she
really is like banking on that whole
idea wholesale like if it doesn't matter
it's trinity or not trinity Jesus not a
god man doesn't matter it's it's all the
same God. I'm like that's her whole
conception. Um,
>> so I'm gonna Hold on. There's time the
25th on the 26:15.
>> I hope the audio does does it well.
Okay, there we go.
>> How long it takes a beginner.
>> There she goes. Man, she was young over
here, huh? I know hijab.
>> Islam and Judaism and Christianity, but
we have one God is the same God. That's
what's called the Abrahamic religions.
You can go ask somebody who's Jewish if
we have the same God.
>> Well, they're still waiting for their
Messiah.
>> That's that's the difference. But there
is one ultimate.
>> The only diff like I see the difference
where I mean Muslims
>> uh accept Jesus Christ
>> of course
>> where
>> as a prophet as a prophet
>> but he's very very important prophet.
>> I mean he's mentioned in the Quran.
>> So is mother Mary very important.
They're mentioned in the Quran. I
Muslims,
>> you can notice from her right away that
she has delved into the Dais, the
classic Dao script.
>> Yeah.
>> So, and a bunch of more statements like
these. And my question to you, Sam,
would be concerning what you're
observing right now.
>> Yes.
>> How [clears throat] can we make Tal
clear that we do not believe in the same
God and she needs to let go of this
claim if she is a person of integrity?
>> Now, I'm surprised these Armenians did
not know how to respond to that.
Well, obviously in order to listen to
their response, you need to listen to
the two-hour thing, which I would would
would not suggest you would do. Uh, but
but they first of all, they're they
attempted stuff. They were trying to
reel her back into the faith. So, they
were not just letting making claims all
of a sudden, but the amount of claims
that she made in or in order to respond
to those claims, it was highly
insufficient. H if Tal was here and I
hope she'll accept my invitation. We can
even do it on your channel. I say,
"Okay, so you're saying my god and your
god are one and the same." I go, "So
then that means you worship the
trinity." So now guys, I'm going to
teach you. We're going to kill several
birds with one stone. [clears throat]
Several birds with one stone by the
power of the Holy Spirit reigning us in
and giving us perfect recall of all
facts, all scripture. Destroy
forgetfulness and error and sin in us.
Reign us in, Holy Spirit. We love you.
We worship you. You are the teacher.
Empower us to glorify the father, the
Lord Jesus Christ, the son, your eternal
love. Bless us and bring her back home
in Jesus name. Now I would say, so then
that means your god is the trinity. So
I'm going to teach you how to get the
Muslims to admit they don't have the
same God you do. I know and I'm already
anticipating objections. Yeah, but
doesn't
say I've already dealt with that.
There's a context behind that. So tal I
I hope they send this to you. So, is
Allah the father, son, and holy spirit?
No. Is your Allah the father of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ? No. Therefore,
your God, Allah of the Quran is not the
God of the Bible. If you want to then
say, well, Jesus spoke Aramaic and he
would have said Allah or Allah or the
Arabic Bible uses Allah. That's not my
argument. I need everyone to listen to
this. I am not arguing
that because you call him Allah, it's a
different God. I am not arguing about
the word Allah.
Just like in English, the term God can
be used by a broad range of people. So
if we have a room, you have
trinitarians, you have Jehovah's
Witnesses, you have Mormons, you have
Orthodox Jews, you have Buddhists, you
have Hindus, and I say, "Praise God," no
one would object. They'll say, "Praise
God. because it's a generic term and a
generic term can be used for any deity.
But when I get specific and I say praise
God, father, son, holy spirit, the only
group is going to amen me are the
trinitarians. So I don't want tal to
attack straw man misrepresent me. I am
not arguing over the term Allah. I'm
arguing that the Allah of the Quran,
that Allah of the Quran is not the Allah
of the Bible. Because if you go to my
Arabic Bible, I'm going to show it to
you. The Arabic Bible calls Jesus Allah
in John 1:1. If you guys don't believe
me, open up your Bibles. If you read in
Arabic, it will say, "In the beginning
was the word. The word was with Allah,
and the word was Allah, and the word
became flesh." That's number one. In
Hebrews 1:8 there, if you read the
Arabic Bible, it says, "But about the
son, he says, "Your throne, Yah Allah."
So I don't want I don't think you want
to go there. The God of the Bible is the
father, the son, and the holy spirit.
Not three gods, not the same person, and
hence the trinity. So when you say we
have the same god, are you saying you
worship Jesus as your god, your Allah?
Then why don't you come back to the
Armenian church? Why did you stray away?
And just to give you some receipts
because we're going to give you
documentation for this. I wrote a series
of responses to a Muslim. Now, which
page I go? See, I right here. Where am
I? Okay, right here. But where am I?
Sorry, man. I got so many pages open. I
don't know where I'm at. Is it right
here?
>> No problem.
>> I gotta I can't even keep up with the
pages, man.
I lost the page. You believe it? How
stupid am I? Sorry, guys. This is what
happens.
Where the hell is Facebook, man? Do you
see the icon for Facebook, bro? Oh, it's
right here.
>> See how slow I am?
>> All right.
>> Doesn't matter. We still appreciate you,
Sam. We don't care what people say about
you,
>> man. Bro, you know what? I was starting
to believe the rumors about you until
then, I repented. So, thank the Lord I
repented for that.
>> Yeah, man.
>> You know, especially what they were
saying about you on that show, on that
Armenian show. Like, man, bro, they're
making a good case against Vart. I said,
"No, I rebuke that." [laughter]
>> Like, let them make a make a case
against me in a debate.
Let's just say Armenian evangelicalism
is a completely different subject. We're
not going to address it right now, but
for some reason, they're blocking me.
Why would that be? I don't know. Anyway,
>> what? They're blocking you? Yeah, Arur,
Rouslan, uh, you name it. Anyway,
different different topic. We'll address
later on.
>> Here's the article. I'm going to use the
Arabic Bible to show that Allah is
applied to father and the son, the Lord
Jesus Christ, and that Jesus said to be
the son of Allah. Now, for some reason,
Rumble, the comments are not showing up.
Is Rumble down?
Yes. See, the comments are not showing
up. I can't see the comments and it
won't let me. There's a problem with
payment from please contact what
payment.
What do I got to pay you for? It's free.
>> Anyway,
>> must be calian.
>> I have no idea. Anyway, forget about it.
Let's go here. Let me show you where the
term Allah is applied to the son Jesus
Christ as well as it's applied to the
father. And Jesus said to be the son of
Allah. Let's go right here. John 1. In
the beginning was the word and the word
was with God. Allah. And the word was
God.
Allah.
>> So you don't want to go there. Both the
father and the son are Allah. You don't
want to go there. Now is also called the
son of Allah which the Quran rejects.
For Allah so loved the world that he
gave his only son. So Allah has a son.
For Allah or Allah sent the sonah.
And whoever does not believe in the name
of the only son of God
al
he is condemned. I don't think you want
to go there. Jabel
is her name. Jabel says that Yeshua he
will be the son of the most high. Ib Ali
and he will be called Iben Allah.
You sure you want to go there? You sure
you want to use my Bible, especially the
Arabic Bible to show you have the same
God? Because that means you must now
worship and glorify father, the son, the
lord Jesus Christ, and the holy spirit
as Allah. And where does the god call
Jesus ya Allah?
Here you go.
But about the son alben, he says, "Your
throne yah Allah."
So no, it's not the same God because our
God is the father, the son who became
flesh, Jesus Christ our Lord, the holy
spirit. And Jesus is the son of Allah.
And yet the Quran says Allah is a father
to no one. Jews and Christians are not a
spiritual children. And if you say Isa
is a son of Allah, Allah will fight you.
You are a pervert. Chapter 9 verse 30 of
the Quran. Now I also have another
challenge for Talal. The
>> Sam my apologies. My apologies for
interrupting. It's not tal. It's tal
with the R.
>> I want to say tal, bro. Tal.
>> Okay. At least you at least you are
aware. I thought you're telling me that
I have abysmal grammar, but now you're
just like writing Armen with double R.
I'm like,
>> hey buddy.
>> I'm thinking it's all this time. likeal
tala. Okay, my apologies. May Allah
abrogate that statement of mine. You're
not tal. Okay. May Allah abrogated.
Okay, we come back now. You such a
hater. Oh, shoot.
>> Sorry. All rightal.
>> You know, you know, you know I'm joking
with you. You know that by now. You know
I love you.
>> But is that her name? Tal or Tal? I
don't get
>> dollarar. Tal
>> like a dollar.
>> Correct. Yeah. Think about think of her.
Think about dollar. Yeah.
>> Okay. I want dollar. Can you give me
dollarar tal? Okay. Anyway, coming back
to the issue, if I mispronounce your
name, may Allah abrogate the
misprononunciation of your name.
>> Yeah. Chapter 2 vers 106. Anyway,
>> you got so
the Bible says Jesus is the son of Allah
and he is Allah who became flesh. Your
Quran says if you say Jesus is the son
of Allah, you are cursed. You're a
pervert. Allah is a father to no one.
The second mistake,
the Arabic form of J name is Yeshua.
Your Quran calls him Isa. Why? So that's
the first problem. Anyway,
>> anyway. Yeah. [clears throat]
One claim which which he shortly
mentioned before is the claim that uh
it's Abrahamic.
The claim that's an Abrahamic religion.
Bogus if you would ask me.
How would you how would we
>> make clear to to our beloved that Islam
is claims to be Abrahamic but nothing of
that is the